ah
[Music]
um
i feel like i found my true calling i
feel like i was
put here to be competitive and to be a
boxer to
prove these people wrong and people have
so much to say about me jake paul isn't
a
boxer ben askren you lose to jake paul
slapping paul
has in my estimation no chance of
beating ben ashraf i'll bet a million
dollars daddy loses this [__] fight
you know i was a kid
at 16 years old mulching lawns digging
holes in people's backyards
with this dream of bigger things in life
to make it out of that
and to get to where i am today i could
give a [__] about what people think i've
already won
time and time again before the nate
robinson fight everyone was like nate
robinson's gonna win
and then once i knocked him out they're
like he's just the nba player
you cheated i have the ace up my sleeve
and knowing that i'm going to destroy
this man and dismantle him in front of
the world
at some point you have to realize like
this is a chess game and
i'm making all the right moves
[Music]
welcome back to the true geordie podcast
on today's episode he's coming back for
the third time
it's jake paul yeah how's it going
what what's up brother how are you ah
man i'm good
yeah i'm good man just just gearing up
for april 17th
you already know mate it's [__] meant
all this for me
because i was interviewing you before
your first fight i didn't really know
you that well
you know i was only learning about who
you were even during the interview
now you are one of the most talked about
people
in entertainment that's it's
mind-blowing you know i mean and you've
done credit here you know you
people might look at you and think what
they want but you know you've made this
happen
um how does that feel at this point
looking back from that deji fight
it's it's been a wild journey
to say the least and it feels almost as
if it's just the start at the same time
and
man it's surreal i think i've sort of
lost
sense of reality and
i'm i'm sort of just a passenger on this
roller coaster ride now
and you know i sort of
worked for this but i i i could never
have imagined it getting this big and
this fast and like you said it's
it's it's just absurd it's it's mad it's
mental
it's pretty crazy seriously like you
know even for me as a fight fund like
you know like yourself i'm a fight fan
your fight with ben askren is one of the
biggest fights of the year now it's
become like
you know i think a lot of people are
looking at things like anthony joshua
and tyson fury but the attention you
guys are getting
is not far behind that i mean it really
is insanely
big this is top five fights of the year
now in my opinion
it's crazy like you said and i i think
it's a perfect match up and people
are people are 50 50. i think that's the
beautiful thing about it is people don't
know what's going to happen
in the fight and that's why it's so
interesting and ben askren you know is
doing a great job of promoting the fight
he's doing a great job of [__] talking
he's doing great at the press
conferences
he's doing great you know making these
rocky training videos
and it's and it's interesting it's it's
these these two worlds colliding
in sort of this heightened moment at a
perfect time
with amazing you know with amazing
production put behind this event with
justin bieber snoop dogg
uh it's electric to say the least
have you got time to go go back through
because i don't know how much time you
got today you got time to sit and chill
for a bit and talk about some of the old
fights and stuff with us
yeah yeah cool let's do it all right so
off the back of that dead g fight we
were uncertain what was going to happen
like were you going to carry on was this
a one and done obviously logan had a
reason to rematch jj but you'd won
decisively you know your music's been
doing great lately it's better than ever
people are
so mad that you must have ghost writers
and everything like it's you know
you can make money off of clothing
youtube why
get in the ring and get punched in the
face when it's a lot easier for you to
make money elsewhere why continue this
you know i love it first and foremost i
have a passion for it
and i feel like i found my true calling
i feel like
i was put here to be competitive and to
be a boxer
and it seems crazy but it's like getting
up and filming every single day or
you know doing youtube or even making
music i love it and it's great but it
it's not my whole entire heart isn't in
it with boxing my whole entire heart's
in it
and it's and it's something that i i
just wake up with a smile on my face to
go and do every single day
um and i love proving people wrong and
and as we know you know i'm one of the
most hated people
in the world you know especially
especially
especially your fan base people in the
uk i'm i'm hated man and
and people have so much to say about me
and i love
to prove these people wrong and
i love to take their negative energy
harness it use it to motivate me and
fuel me
and to continue to propel my career and
so
with all that said you know it's it's uh
it's my calling really and on top of
that at the end of the day i've always
been an entrepreneur
i've always been a businessman and
there's no money like boxing money
um and so you know for people to say
you know for boxers to say like oh the
money doesn't drive me or
or whatever they're gonna say or i do it
because
you know i've been fighting my whole
life that's cool you know a lot of
that's true but
this is a big business at the end of the
day and i'm definitely also
also partially driven by how enormous
this business can be
let's go back to your first boxing
sessions
pre the deji fight can you tell me what
they were like how it
felt because you know most of the time
when you're at that situation you're
just getting your ass kicked daily
um what was that like for you it was
brutal
i was really put through the ringer at
the time my coach was
milton who obviously still coaches logan
and he didn't give a [__] about
our feelings he didn't give a [__] if we
were sore he didn't give a [__] if we
were getting beat up
he was throwing this in there with real
professionals
who were unloading on us and that was
really the only way to learn is
is to get that experience and to get
beat up
if you're the best person in the room at
anything or if you're the smartest
person in the room at anything you're
not doing you're not
that's not where you should be in life
always surround yourself with people who
are better than you
and that's what we really did and man we
would
wake up every single day and get punched
in the face get beaten up
all these professionals coming in and it
wasn't easy at all
by any means and that's why i say boxing
is you can't play boxing it's one of the
hardest things if not the hardest thing
i've ever done in my life
we just sent it and we i really had no
idea what i was getting myself
into at the time you know fast forward
three and a half years i i look at the
fighter who who i was
and how far i've come is is uh
it's unreal yeah i wanted to talk about
that because i went and watched that
fight
before this interview and you know you
can see there's talent
in and you clearly dominated the fight i
think a lot of people
don't remember the fight the way it
really was because there was that one
picture of you
bloodied up but you you pieced them up
and you were on the front foot the
majority of the time
i just think deji did better than some
people expected but
i looked at your technique you know the
power is clearly there but you you just
don't seem aware at the time of how to
apply it how to turn your body into the
punches and the technique that you've
got now
is clearly world support but what did
you learn from that fight
looking back on it honestly that was one
of the
hardest things i've ever had to do i had
to dig so deep into that fight
where you know you're in manchester
arena 25 000 people cheering against me
i really had to dig to a place that i've
never had a dig before
any anywhere in life i really
felt so animalistic and felt like a lion
and
it was all sort of this blur and i i
learned
just how far i can push myself and and
how mentally tough i actually
am and i prove to myself that night that
night that i'm a warrior
and that it's it's gonna take you know
a bullet to stop me um because i i won't
i won't stop fighting
and it's an experience that changed my
life
uh forever just the the feelings the
adrenaline dump
everything about it getting hit in the
face and i i sort of had this rush of
emotion of like
all of these people in this in this
stadium are the ones who are
on twitter saying [__] jake paul that's
why i wore that chain
out out there because it's like i'm here
to prove tonight to all of these people
that
i i can't be beaten and all of y'all
might think you know me but
y'all don't know me and that was the
last time i remember seeing you nervous
as well you were a little more nervous
in that fight obviously it was your
first fight
like you say 20 000 people every time
you get punched
they're cheering compare that to the gib
fight
you were called killer it was a total
different guy the
the progression was massive you
trained with sugar shame mosley in big
bay
for that what was that whole experience
like training with a world champion in a
legend like that
i think that was my first taste of like
real professional boxing
and a real real training camp
you know i was nestled away in the
mountains
you know only focused on boxing we were
snowed in every single day we would
go outside to the gym box come back
have some food go back in box there was
no distractions i wasn't vlogging during
that time
and shane uh threw me to the sharks in
that camp against some
undefeated pros who
once again were beating my ass but i
went in there every single day with them
and slowly gradually started catching up
and
started to learn defense and
professional punching using my hips
turning punches over
and setting things up and
really just how to relax in the ring as
well like you said for that first fight
i had no idea what i was getting myself
into
so once i had that experience under my
belt and a ton more sparring sessions
under my belt
i finally felt like i started to
understand what this sport was about
and and credit to you your performance
was fantastic because i've been in the
ring with gabe sparred with him
and the guy brings it you know he
doesn't let you relax and he
that he caught you with a shot early on
but you stayed composed
and you didn't let the the occasion get
the better of you
what is it that you felt that you proved
in that fight or you that you learned
from that fight
so i mean
basically amateur fights are a lot
different than amateur fights and
sparring is a lot different than going
into a pro fight because in the amateurs
you have the head gear on you have the
bigger gloves in sparring you have the
head gear on you have the bigger gloves
i'm sure gibb is really tough and
sparring he's coming forward and
you know is taking all those punches but
he can block them he has the head gear
on he's going to be fine and sparring
but once you take those big gloves off
and the head gear off
it's it's a whole different story and my
coaches were leading up to the fight
we're like jake you have power
you know i i think you're gonna knock
this kid out and i was like okay
sure like i have power
i've never really knocked someone out
before maybe like once
i knocked someone down and sparring
before um
but they were like no you're gonna
you're gonna drop this kid and
i didn't really believe them i didn't
know if i had that conf i didn't really
have that confidence
like i knew i was gonna do well but i
didn't have that confidence of like
i can really crack and so
we get into the first round and i'm
barely clipping gibb
on the top of the head these aren't even
clean punches that i'm landing and
you know he he's he goes down the unit
gets knocked down three times
and so after that fight it's like damn
my coaches were right and
i finally felt like what it was like to
crack with those 10 oz gloves on
that was a hell of a performance and and
um the change
moving from milton to shane mosley
seemed to have paid off
what was it that made you want to leave
milton when obviously he is still with
your brother
this day yeah it's it's interesting um
and all credit to milton uh you know i
think i think he's a great coach
for me what i saw was
something that wasn't working right
milton and shannon
trained logan for for the ksi fight
and it just didn't add up
right and uh i wanted to just see
right like you don't get married to the
first girl you ever meet in life
right so i wanted it i wanted to see you
know who else is out there what other
coaches what other styles
am i going to like this person a little
bit more and sort of when i got with
shane
mosley and bj flores up in big bear
that sort of just felt right it felt
like this is what i've been missing
and i haven't looked back since you know
i'm still with bj flores
uh till this day and
if the uh if it's not broke don't fix it
right
and at that point obviously ksi gets in
the ring
that fight seemed nailed on the face off
was electric
everyone wanted it immediately covad
comes a few months later delays
everything
and then that fight seems to have gone
off the radar now
uh what's your current feelings on the
situation
i don't even know what to say anymore on
it you know i feel like i've done my
part
uh i've tried to make it happen you know
we're in touch with
with his manager and
you know there's this back and forth i
really don't even want to start any more
beef at this point like
ksi is doing his thing he he feels the
need to
comment on everything i'm doing you know
he's posting instagram stories
about my press conference like it's
almost
like he's just paying attention to
everything i'm doing every step i'm
making
he's helping promote my fight so
i i don't know i don't know what what's
going on with it
i'm ready to fight i've been saying it
for two years now you know i beat your
brother i beat your best friend
at this i really genuinely think and
that that he's ducking me and his
coaches have even said it
and this seems this is gonna seem crazy
and ksi fans are gonna
you know go crazy and say that some
[__] but it's like i'm here
i'm ready i'll fight ksi whenever
wherever i said he could be the a side
i said we can do it in london
and we can do it anytime anyplace
fair enough man there's just nothing
there's just nothing from his side so
it is what it is after that obviously we
set up with uh
the nate robinson fight and it seemed
like bj flores became the head coach
then rather than
like the assistant coach i guess to
shane
what made that decision happen how did
you come to that
so shane was just super busy he has a
whole family
he's traveling around and he wasn't
really able to make the 100 time
commitment
um and bj was like sure like
you know i'll come and live with you in
calabasas
and we can train literally every single
morning
every single night and get this working
so sure enough bj flies to calabasas
and we just start to get to work and two
weeks later
covet hits and at that point obviously
we didn't know what was going to happen
but i just so happened to be quarantined
with my
coach and there wasn't anything to do
really at the time besides train
so it was almost this blessing in
disguise where i was literally just
working on boxing
non-stop day in and day out
sort of wondering okay when is the
united states going to open up
am i gonna be able to fight who am i
gonna fight uh flash forward a couple
months
and there's rumors of events starting to
happen and mike tyson and his team call
me up
and they're like hey we're doing an
event
we want you to be the co-main event
who do you want to fight and that's sort
of how it happened
your brain must have been like what the
hell because
to share a card with mike tyson very few
people
can say that like that's a story for
your grandkids one day like
how does that feel we've even been in
that situation
it's still surreal to me um and it's a
dream come true
you know my family is so proud of me for
that accomplishment
i i i can't believe it and
even when even when you know they got on
the phone with me i was like
are you [__] me i literally remember
getting off the phone i was like
i literally started running around my
house and my friends were like what
what what and i'm like i'm going to
fight on a mike tyson undercard
this is lit this is so big and
it's it's historic like like you said
and you stole the show as well by the
way like this is the thing
you fought on a mike tyson card and the
only fight people were really talking
about the day after
was yours so you did the business how
did
that was heard around the world on you
know what i mean like you you were
basically
the regular mainstream sports media had
to pay attention to you because you just
knocked out an actual athlete now it
wasn't just a youtuber
yeah i think that was the goal the whole
entire time you know my coaches started
saying it to me they were like
jake you need to steal the show this is
this is
your moment to shine and that was our
motto the whole entire training camp is
that we're going to steal the show
and i believe if you if you say
something enough times and manifest it
enough then it's going to happen and
you know all credit to my team we've
assembled such an amazing
team over the past year
and we just put our head down in las
vegas and
grinded non-stop and
everyone thought that nate robinson not
everyone but
a lot of people thought that nate
robinson was going to beat me because
he's this athlete
and he's super buff and
that's that's why it shocked the world
because
they just didn't understand that i can
actually fight and that
a basketball player or any athlete can't
just come over and learn how to box in
three or four months this is something
that i am passionate about and have been
doing for a really long time
and and that was the difference between
the gib fight you said you shot yourself
with the gib
fight like the power that you had oh i
can crack
now when you knock nate robinson out you
walk off like
you just sort of took the dog for a walk
it was no big deal
so it seems like the training had
obviously stepped up a level because
that felt very normal to you at that
point
yeah so sort of leading up to that fight
while we were training in vegas my i
just exponentially grew as a fighter
and i was knocking out sparring partners
you know in every other session leading
up to that fight and so i was just used
to it
and i was like if i'm doing this in
sparring with the big gloves on
as soon as i put these small gloves on
nate robinson who's never
sparred like this or been hit by me
is gonna go down instantaneously and
that's why i was
so confident going into that fight i
talked a lot of [__]
i said first round the whole entire time
going into it and i just i told this i
was like yo
nate robinson's kids like don't watch
this fight because it's going to be bad
that was a good line by the way i like
that life
thank you and
actually the training footage that you
put out
the a lot of those knockouts i was
listening to a podcast recently where
khabib's
coach the head of um aka
mma gym he said look like this guy is
legit
like you don't just knock people out
like this as much as he is early on like
there's real talent here a lot of people
might be overlooking him because they
don't like him
but like this is a guy who trained kane
velasquez and
daniel cormier and khabib and world
champions and he's like
i'm saying talent don't sleep on him
just because he's a youtuber so
i think yeah i think that is a part of
your part of the reason you're going to
be underestimated even
for a little while no matter what
happens is that in in a weird way it
kind of
it's almost working to your advantage do
you think
a hundred percent like i love
being underestimated i love to see all
of these
mma fans right now just talking mad [__]
about how i'm gonna lose and how i'm
gonna be embarrassed and
you know a bunch of mma fighters telling
ben askren to knock me out
i have the ace up my sleeve and knowing
that i am going to destroy this man and
dismantle him in front of the world
and people are going to be in shock and
awe
but i'm and my team
are we're just gonna sit here and be
like yep yeah we told you
and if you go back if you go back to
every single press conference and every
single
interview leading up to my previous
fights
i i predict exactly what's going to
happen
and this this will this will be no
different and people will go back and
really start to realize that i'm not
just i'm talking a lot of [__] because i
know
what i'm capable of and you know i'm not
just saying this because you know we're
cool and you know we've been
mates for a while like i fully agree
with you and believe you in this
like i listened to an interview with bj
flores your coach
and it was about an hour long and after
that i was just so
confident because when your coach is as
smart as he is
i know you're getting the right training
i was really impressed with this guy
this is high level strike and he's
teaching you for real
and um on on the ben askren situation
obviously you called out a lot of people
why did it end up being ben askren yeah
uh i think it just came down to
who was actually gonna sign the contract
and
we sort of narrowed it down to three or
four people
i i was waiting for mcgregor because we
were actually talking to mcgregor's
manager and there was you know there was
hopes of that happening
and there was talks of that happening so
we were sort of delaying to see
what was going to happen with the ufc
and
it came down to asgrain and dylan danis
and ascertain was down
and it seemed as if no none of these
other mma fighters really wanted to step
up to the plate
um and it's the perfect fight at the end
of the day
it's it's mma guy you know ncaa champion
olympic athlete versus you know disney
disney channel kid
i mean he was a legit mma champion
multiple organizations like the guy is
legit and that's that's the great thing
about this is
people can't deny you if you if you beat
an mma
champion in a boxing match you're a
badass i don't give a [__] what anyone
says do you know what i mean but
um can you remember the moment where you
started thinking
are i [__] fighting youtubers and
athletes i want to fight
a fighter now an actual pro fighter can
you remember that moment
just because yeah just because um right
after i knocked out nate robinson
everyone was like oh you
you didn't knock out a real fighter so
before the nate robinson fight everyone
was like nate robinson's gonna win
and then once i knocked him out there
like he's just the nba player
you cheated you like i don't know
there's a million excuses being made up
yeah and so i was like all right
like i'll fight a real fighter and at
the end of the day if i would have
gotten in there with another
youtuber no one right now would really
care the sports world wouldn't really
care
the mma community wouldn't really care
it would sort of stay in this
youtube realm of fights
i'm trying to do bigger things i'm
trying to expand outside of
that audience and become
global and become a global fighter and
the only way to do that is to actually
fight against a real fighter
who has all this sports media around him
and to defeat him and that's how that's
how this
narrative keeps on growing and growing
and growing
you know i could have went in there and
knocked out
austin mcbroom or you know whoever these
other guys that are fighting in these
other events now
but no one really would have
been impressed or would have cared as
much
yeah i mean you've definitely made
people care and i think that's one of
the things that people don't see how
smart you are is
you know how to make people [__] care
about things you're doing and
the mma world really [__] cares like
they are
praying you lose and it's funny to me
because
you know someone who i grew up loving
mma but i also know
how the mma farm base can be they can be
very emotional actually because
you know it's a manly man thing but they
get really precious
over the idea of some youtube kid coming
in and knocking out an mma champion
but even like pros like i'm looking i've
got
some quotes here from chael sonnen who
was saying you know he is convinced ben
ben's just going to win this and i was
looking at his reasoning he was like ben
isn't going to come here and box
he's coming to compete and he's going to
find a way to win because that's what
ben
does and then you've also got um jsp's
coach for assahabi very respected
saying things like ben takes a shot
better than jake so
asgrin is going to take over the fight
as jake
fades when he can't knock him out with
one punch and and then he's going to
basically mull him in the clinch this is
the this is the constant thing i'm
hearing from all mma voices is
you're going to fade because you won't
be able to knock him out cause his
chin's so good
because he's so tough and then he takes
over the fight
what do you think of that i think it's
hilarious i think
again i have the ace up my sleeve and
these guys don't know what i'm capable
of
they don't know how hard i could hit and
sure ben has a has a great chin
you know he he's been hit by robbie
lawler a couple of times
but this guy is just coming off of a
knockout he's coming off of a loss
and to sit here and think that
this old guy ben askren
has or for people to say that he has a
better cardio than me or that i'm going
to get tired is absolutely hilarious ben
askren
can't work as hard as me in one practice
you know like
my one practice is harder than his whole
entire training camp
and i believe he's gonna be tough but at
the end of the day this is boxing
and he can't take me down after i start
cracking him
he can try and come in and clinch me
he can try and hold on but he's gonna
get warned for that right off the bat
and you can't just hold on to people in
boxing
and it's a very different sport than mma
and anyone who understands both sports
should really truly understand that
and look i've been sparring against mma
guys this whole entire camp
leading up to this who are unorthodox
who are wrestlers
who come in and try and clinch me it
does not
matter nothing that ben askren will try
to do
in this fight will matter for one moment
and again actions speak louder than
words and i'm just going to prove it to
people and gsp's coach
i'm sure he's a great guy uh kale chael
sonnen
uh you know dope guy
but i'm i'm sorry you guys are in for a
rude awakening and you're going to see
you're going to see tune in april 17th
what do you think of um of ben's
sparring footage i'm sure you've seen it
um yeah i've seen it i i don't know what
to make of it
you know who knows i i don't i don't
care about it
to say the least you know like
it doesn't really matter to me what he's
doing and that's sort of my point
even with the last question is i don't
care about what ben asking is doing
i don't care about what ben askren does
april 17th i don't care what his game
plan is
i don't care about his skills because
anything that
he does i will have an answer to
i have sparred against better fighters
than him
this whole entire camp every single
person that i've sparred in this camp is
better than ben askren
and quite literally april 17th will be
the easiest training session
from the whole entire camp every single
day of this camp
will be harder than what the actual
fight night is i'm gonna go in there
and fight someone who
is a lesser opponent than all of these
guys i've sparred i'm gonna drop him in
six minutes or less and i'm gonna
[__] walk out of the arena
and that's that i really personally
don't understand what the [__]
these people are saying when they when
they're saying this because i look at
ben's
you know striking in mma it's it's
laughable
he is a great wrestler no doubt he can
grapple but
his striking is purely he sometimes he
overreaches overextends constantly
he literally is square on he's running
at people
trying to land a punch he's he's
available to be cracked just the same
way
you crack nate robinson exactly the same
sort of stuff
and then i watch him on pads the guy is
slow he's not powerful
i i'm when they're saying he's going to
do things i'm like
what with what though like the guy isn't
going to have the speed or the power
or the technique to hang with you you
can be as tough as you want
but when jake paul's got way better
skill the
all their hope is is that you're just
not as tough as him i'm like
what do you think this guy guy is how do
you think he got that good you don't get
that good
without going through grueling training
camps this is mental
no exactly and and they and they don't
believe in my uh
cardio you know let's say the fight goes
eight rounds
so be it let's let it go eight rounds
all i'm saying is the end result
will be jake paul winning and i'm i'm
prepared to go in deep waters
i i could give a [__] about eight rounds
eight eight rounds is a walk into the
in a park for me i'm throwing 125 to 150
punches around
in sparring for eight rounds let's
[__] go
like come on guys yeah hey welcome to
the
welcome to the show in regards to how
tough you are
like i'm just wondering you know
if you could describe what how hard
these sparring sessions have been you
know have you been dropped or
have you been hit extremely hard like
what level do you feel like you've had
to go to in order to be ready for this
uh we're all we're going 100
in sparring at all times against world
champions
you know and we're going full go and
this is something that people don't
understand
everyone thinks that i'm just like
taking pictures with these world
champions and
posting it up online and everyone's like
oh he was they were probably going easy
on him that's what they say yeah
they're probably just working
no ladies and gentlemen no we are
going on 100 percent and that's why i'm
saying this
fight will be the easiest day of
training camp
and i have been in there with over 250
guys
in the past two years and i've seen
every look i've seen every style
and i've been cracked in the face full
on
right hands multiple times and it
doesn't affect me i've said it before i
like to get hit
i i hope i hope ben askren hits me
good in this fight because to me it's
not even a fight
in sparring until i get hit and
that's what sort of like wakes me up
that's what's like okay let's get it
let's get it that's i love the sport it
goes back to my passion
for it you have to be a little bit crazy
or a little bit odd to wake up
and want to go get punched in the face
for a living
and do it again and do it again and do
it again and do it again it takes a
certain breed and that's what i truly
don't think people understand is that
i'm the real deal and again actions
speak louder than words this is my
coming out party and
april 17th again the mma community is
gonna be
left with his jaws dropped and these
people are gonna swallow their words
you were face to face with ben at the
press conference what was it like being
up close with him for the first time
uh really like no emotions uh
honestly you know he was sort of just
smiling and
at the end of the day i think he he's
doing this
for the wrong reasons is what it feels
like to me and i sort of
see through his [__] and a lot of people
are like oh ben askren won the press
conference ben askren
you know is in jake's head and blah blah
blah and it's like
hey i didn't i didn't swing on him you
know
he was provoked to try and hit me in the
face and
we go upstairs to do a one-on-one
interview with snoop dogg hosting it
after the press conference and the guy
just feels defeated almost to me
and his confidence is null
and he's again in for rude awakening i
think at the end of the day he thinks
this is
all a marketing ploy for me to hype this
fight up
he thinks i'm genuinely trying to fool
people into thinking i'm a real fighter
and he's underestimating the [__] out of
me um
just like all of my sorry man he accused
you of being a bully
in the press conference
again it's like this is the fight game
right like he he could
he could choose another sport to be a
part of you know i think all is fair
in love and war and this is war for me
what did you think of the incident where
he seemed to i don't know how he would
even describe that but yeah when the
face off happened
how did you feel when he reacted in the
way he did
well first and foremost you know i i
didn't expect him
to be trying to try and hit me at all
and so i wasn't even prepared for that
and
i block his arm move away from it like
it just
it just shows that he's slow and
i don't know my reflexes are just like
um but a lot of people criticize the
moment they're like oh
you didn't you didn't you punched or you
slapped him in the stomach or you didn't
hit him or because of that moment that i
just saw now i know that ben askren's
uh gonna win is what people were saying
and to me i wanted to knock him out
right there like i wanted to come around
and
clock him in the chin but i made a split
second decision not to because
if i would have knocked him out there
the commission wouldn't have let him
fight
and he would have an excuse as to maybe
why he got
knocked out april 17th oh i got knocked
out at the press conference
he hit me in the face or i can't fight
or my jaw is broken
or whatever so i made a business
decision not to knock him out right
there on the spot
which a lot of people criticized but in
hindsight i made the right decision
yeah i mean you don't want to [__] up
the money uh you know you want to get
paid for this and uh
you know why do you think he did that
though like because it
a lot of people were giving him credit
because it was a funny moment and you
know as you know people don't like you
so anytime anyone does anything towards
you they're going to love that
but for as a fan of of the fight game
knowing him he's normally very laid back
and he was laid back that whole time but
in my opinion for him to raise his hand
it showed a slight i don't know like
mentally
that isn't his style usually i was
surprised by it
no exactly i mean in all of his fights
and his career he's never tried to push
someone in a face off
and so you know who knows i don't read
too much into it though again like
it's it you know this is entertainment
the press conferences are built for
entertainment and for hype
and that's exactly what happened is that
moment hyped up the fight
three times more so it's all
this is all a w this is all a w at the
end of the day
and he shouldn't have done that
you know because it it's uh
it's it's gonna be worse for him once
i'm once i'm putting that beating on him
he's gonna feel that he's gonna feel
that one of the one of the biggest
personalities who commented on that was
daniel cormier i think you've seen this
where
he said now i now because of jake's
reaction
i know ben is winning that fight
what is it like seeing people react like
this
i think he's an idiot i think he
if you think that you can predict a
fight based off of
how someone reacts to someone else
getting pushed in the face
in the heat of the moment uh you're just
stupid
there's there's nothing that you can
sort of take away from that
of course dc is gonna say that because
he's an mma fan
and he's gonna back his boy one of the
people
who's commented on this fight and that
this was when i knew
like jake has just gone full blown
[__] mainstream
was when dana white bet a million
dollars
that you were gonna lose against ben
askren
what was that like for you
i mean i i was just like i was blown
away by
like you said how how big this has
gotten and how
how many people care and how many people
have an opinion
towards this fight and
you know my brother's supposedly
fighting floyd mayweather who who knows
what's happening and i've seen
multiple people even people on your
podcast being like look
we want to see the jake paul versus ben
askren fight more more than the floyd
versus logan fight
and i think that's that's that sort of
aura that's been created and
um this fight almost can't be ignored
that's how electric it is and i was just
surprised that dana is really talking
about anything besides the ufc
yeah it says a lot when i mean
you're gonna give ben askren a bigger
payday than dana white ever did and
you're actually promoting ben askren
better than day and i ever did also so
like
you're doing a pretty [__] good job i
mean dana should be looking at you for
tips
on this really well and i've said that
to dana i mean
i've gone back and forth with him
multiple times on insta stories
talking mad [__] to him he's like oh
jake's not a real fighter and blah blah
i'm like dana
like let me fight conor mcgregor because
i'm connor's money fight right now and
that that seems crazy and everyone's
gonna hate and you're gonna have all the
[__] sheeps come in and listen to all
the other people and everyone's gonna
form their sheep opinions uh about what
they think about jake paul versus
mcgregor
at the end of the day it's like dana
you're talking about me more than i'm
talking about you at this point and
the the truth truth be told like
we're doing a bigger promotion than any
of your recent fights
statistically so
i can sit here and talk [__] like i'm
not
when i come on these podcasts and do
these interviews
it's it's almost uh it's almost like
i can't do anything right if you already
hate jake paul like no one comes on here
and is like wow this is i'm gonna form a
different opinion on jake paul after
this interview it's like no
people already have such strong opinions
on me that
people are just watching at this point i
don't even [__] know why but
like like it's it's meant
it's mental to me because at some point
you have to realize like
this is a chess game and i'm making all
the right moves
and i i like i sort of i'm on a tangent
right now i've sort of lost my train of
thought
going bro keep going i just
i don't i don't get oh that's what i was
gonna say is numbers don't lie
so i'm sitting here chatting all this
[__] probably making more people hate me
but i'm just sitting here with the facts
i'm just sitting here with the numbers
we did the eighth biggest pay-per-view
event of all time and people say oh it's
mike tyson and he sold everything
cool say what you want to say make all
these excuses
but look where we are and
this is historic and people are tuning
in regardless of whether they hate me or
not so at the end of the day
you know all the hate all the comments
it's only fueling the fire in regards to
the ufc
i know you're a big mma fan but has this
whole experience
changed how you feel about it with the
way the fans have been
no no um you know i still love the ufc
and i still watch all the fights just
like i have since i was a kid i just
think
you know dana white is sometimes a
dumbass and
has too big of an ego and i think a lot
of people feel that way when i started
talking [__] about dana white so many
people hit me up and we're like keep
going
keep going but a lot of people are
afraid to go after dana and talk [__]
about him because
he has a lot of power in the fight game
but i do agree with you about the ego
though because
in that conversation he was having with
mike tyson and um
it was zab judah i believe uh
they were bigging you up a little bit
and i felt like his
he went quiet for a minute and then just
was like i bet a million dollars and it
was like
it did feel reactionary like our guys
would beat your guys sort of thing or i
don't know what
where that was coming from but it did
seem a massive overreaction
to where the conversation was because
all all
zab said was this guy has hands he can
actually fight
and he didn't seem to like that um
what does it feel like to hear zab and
mike bigging you up
like that having your back honestly
uh it means a lot to me and
in a weird way so many people
throughout my journey have just like
turned a cold shoulder to me or
always end up on the other side of jake
paul
or always end up you know just wanting
to talk [__] about me i don't i don't
know what it is
i think it's largely a part of like me
becoming such a big
name and maybe people being jealous
because i'm young or
whatever but mike and zab
both have my back and mike has had my
back to this day
and it's sort of taking me under under
his wing and to me it mean
it means a lot that someone on that
level
is showing respect to me because a lot
of these guys you'll see just end up
talking [__] yeah there was there was an
interesting point mike made
and he said about you he said there's
something wrong with that kid
but in a good way like like he i he
connects a bit with that side of you
that you have of
like um i don't know mentally you've got
that ruthless streak
and i think he can see that uh but when
mike tyson says there's something wrong
with you that's like the weirdest
compliment anyone can get
no it was uh it was a special moment for
sure
for them to sit there and and have my
back because i
i sort of feel like a lone wolf in this
industry in this process in this journey
i feel like
i'm paving my own path and you know
people love my brother and people love
ksi and i'm sort of i'm sort of public
enemy number one
and i feel i feel like this lone wolf
and so
you know when you show when people show
that lone wolf love
you know the lone wolf is like whoa this
is weird no one's ever really embraced
me like this and
um i get it when i when i say on my
podcast
when we talk about the fight and i go
jake paul's going to smash
ben askren the comments the messages
why are you sucking jake paul off like
the people they hate you then they start
hating me because i'm speaking up for
you like
like you know what i'm saying like it is
pretty bad like i can only imagine how
bad it must be sometimes
no for sure you know i think anyone who
shows
any sort of positivity towards me if
people look at them
it's become a thing to make me the odd
person out
i i say this and it's it's sort of funny
but
um my fans and the people who really
ride or die for me
are very similar to like
not in the same regard but they're very
they're similar to like donald trump
supporters right like you don't
you don't hear people who are like i
love donald trump and
some some people do but like a lot of
donald trump supporters
in the recent election were silent they
don't say anything they just go about
their business
and jake jake paul fans are sort of the
same way they're just sort of silent
because
you know they know that if they speak up
people are like oh what the [__] [__]
that kid he's a [__]
yeah you know he's such an arrogant
[__] and
um so my fans are sort of silent
supporters and
uh but at the end of the day they're
also like some of the best fans
supporters so i'm really thankful for
them and i don't get to say it enough
honestly
yeah i respect that mate and um i think
one of the reasons why people may have
been turned off you in the past
may weirdly be one of the reasons why
you've taken the boxing so well is like
you know um back in these the team 10
days and all of that when you were still
a kid
you were seen to be this sort of um
kind of cold ruthless boss like someone
who's very decisive very
you know makes a decision and that's it
it's done um
do you think some of those personality
traits weirdly that hindered you in
youtube or
maybe turn people against you are now
part of the reason why you're such a
natural
at boxing
yeah no for sure i think it's
i think you have to be sort of ruthless
in the sport of boxing and
uh you have to be a savage if you will
um but you know i don't i don't know i
don't really look too much into my past
man i
i've grown up on camera
i've lived this [__] crazy life i've
gone through many different variations
i've learned
a lot of hard lessons i
have come a long way i i hate the old
version of myself i hate
the one month ago version of myself i'm
constantly evolving
and
i i think that jake paul doesn't
come across on camera as how i am in
real life
um and it's this it's this weird problem
that i've been trying to figure out for
maybe the past two years like ever since
i stopped vlogging like how do i get
people to understand me
or how do i get them to truly
see who i am and i
it almost feels like an uphill battle
because
no matter what i do p i don't think
people want to
take a different approach in looking at
me or my journey or what i'm doing
in terms of the the online hate i mean
i've really struggled at times with it
mate like i'm not
like mental health-wise like it's it's
it's had me in the [__] dumps you
know many times and
i felt really low and i look at the hate
you get and i think god that's probably
way more than i get um but you seem to
cope with it really well
why is that do you think
because i know who i am at the end of
the day
and not a single thing that someone says
or comments can alter that and i know
i'm a good person i know i have a good
heart
and i could give a [__] really about
what anyone says it doesn't affect me
i'd much rather
live in real life than
you know worrying about what people are
saying about me online
and look at where i've come
look at what i've done you know i was a
kid
mulching at 16 years old mulching lawns
digging holes in people's backyards
with this dream of bigger things in life
and accomplishing bigger things in life
and to come from a landscaper a broke
10 an hour landscaper 16 year old kid in
west lake ohio where no one makes it out
of
no one's successful no one's famous
to make it out of that and to to get to
where i am today
i could give a [__] about what people
think i've already won
time and time again me me
moving to los angeles and making five
thousand dollars off of a vine brand
deal when i was 17 years old that was a
big enough w for me
so to go from there to here
there is not a single thing that people
can try and strip away from me
and i'm proud of myself my family's
proud of me
and i was i texted my brother this the
other day i'm like bro like think about
what we've come from
this is truly remarkable
and that's good enough for me
and you just can't take away what i've
accomplished and uh
i focus on the positive really and it's
it's hard to when there's so much
negative
but i think that's how everyone should
live their lives
in regards to people saying you was the
bad guy as you put it earlier with the
people loving logan and logan being the
favorite one in
ksi and that um you you kind of lent
into that a little bit it seems or was
that was that a deliberate thing
in regards to like how floyd did and
other other bad guys have capitalized on
people wanting them to lose
or are you just being you i i'm being me
i'm being me a hundred percent it's just
like
it's uphill battle right you know i i
think
i think people have made me the bad guy
and there there's no
there's no coming out of that really at
this point or anytime
soon and it just is what it is and yeah
now now i sort of just embrace it
i rate that me i think it's it's good
that you just think [__] it let them
think what they want um
i've got a lot of respect for the way
you've dealt with it actually um
obviously we've all made mistakes
and you know i know me and you both but
i think it's great how you just let it
roll off and go [__] it i'm gonna make
as much money as i can and
let give them something to hate you know
um
we meant we've mentioned floyd a couple
of times obviously the the
your brother has got a fight scheduled
with him i'm hearing rumors that it
it could be in the near future um
how does that whole situation make you
feel
because it is that is crazy too well
look at at first i
i sort of was like whoa are you serious
and i i wanted to talk [__] about it
i think i think i was jealous maybe
of logan getting a massive fight and
i my first initial reaction was like ah
this this shouldn't happen and then
and then i sort of realized like no this
is
monumental and
no matter what logan wins
no matter what the outcome of the fight
doesn't matter logan
wins in that situation uh no matter what
and i think it took me a second to
realize
that and realize where he was coming
from and taking that fight
and it just goes to show the power of
the platform
that we've both created and this is the
future of fights
the future of fights is giving something
to the people that they actually want to
watch and talk about
me and my friends were sitting there
talking about floyd versus logan for 30
minutes and i literally was like guys
like timeout this is exactly
why this is so interesting we just
talked about this [__] for 30 minutes
if the people are talking about you
that means they're interested that means
they're invested
and that means they'll watch the fight
and so all kudos to him and
obviously if he knocks the floyd out
he's gonna be god
so i mean you're right though like even
when we do previews on uh on my channel
like you know when we talk about you or
logan fighting someone
the numbers don't lie you know we we do
you know
quote unquote real fight previews that
don't do half the views
so there's a reason why people are
watching if they want to [__] on it they
can talk [__]
whatever they want but they care enough
to click on it that's for damn sure
and i think it's great that you admit
that you're a bit jealous of of logan
and
that's you gotta be a big man to just
admit when you felt that way and it's
only normal i mean
it is a a great thing but i guess for me
the way i see it is like
when logan went through what he went
through
and uh with his situation you both got
towed with the same brush so
i think you also win together you know
like when one of you climbs a mountain
it's like you both did really it so it
doesn't matter
i know 100 and it's really interesting
because
and i sort of just realized this like
the other day
i was like logan is my only competitor
like logan is really the only person who
i can look
towards as competition
there's nobody else and that's why i
think our relationship has always been
this sort of weird
dial of figuring out what it is because
we love each other so much and we're
best friends
but we're the only other people to look
to for competition
because we're the only ones really
innovating like this where the only ones
who are thinking
so outside the box were the only ones
who work as hard as we do
no one in this industry or i don't even
know what this industry is anymore
because i think we've created our own
box but no
no one works as hard as us no one is as
dedicated as us
and people can say that's cocky or
whatever but i
i really don't give a [__] about what
people are saying i'm talking to you
true geordie like
i'm a friend right now i could give a
[__] if anyone else is listening
honestly i've come to the conclusion
that
logan is my only competitor and so
it's this weird thing where i look to
him as inspiration
i look to him as a competitor
as a brother and as a best friend so
it's a super
cool thing that i sort of had an
epiphany on the other day
um and i think it's helped me earn
respect
a lot more respect for him and a lot
more love for him
question if you had been born an only
child
and it was just you and logan was didn't
exist would you have achieved what
you've achieved
without him 100 100 i think that i think
that goes both ways
you know i think we continue to shock
each other and continue to
expand off of each other and we're ying
and yang
quite literally um we we've both
gotten to the the same place
in life on very different paths
and at the end of the day we're from the
same parents and so i think it's a
testament to our parents of like how we
were raised and
and uh and our mental capacity and
how we think about life and just our
ability to show up every single day for
the past seven years
um but honestly i wouldn't want to do
this without my brother
i i think it's so cool that we're doing
this together
and again if you if you look back
to everything we started a youtube
channel called
zeus together when i was like 10 and he
was 12.
this is how it all started is logan and
jake
it's uh it's it's never
it's never been one or the other and
people like to compare us
and that's natural and people like to
say you know who's better
who's this and that just adds again
fuel to the fire and people are talking
about us and
you know let's let them let them talk
let them think what they want
a question about the boxing ability of
you two because obviously that is often
compared and i know ben brought that up
to sort of try and rail you in the
in the press conference um obviously you
feel like you're a better boxer
than than your brother which i think um
you know
right now in the eyes of a lot of people
you are the best youtube boxer because
of what you've been able to do in the
ring but i was wondering
in terms of your makeup you know you
guys know each other so well
what is it about you as a person that
you think
enables you to be better in the ring
than your brother
i think
in my life i have a lot
like growing up i i had a lot of pain
and a lot of
emotion and a lot of built up anger
almost
in a weird way and maybe even like
resentment
towards my parents or i don't know what
it is but
there was always this like really big
like edge to me and i think that's where
sort of
the problem child nickname comes from is
me lashing out and me
being this like i don't i don't even
know how to describe it but
i think i carry that with me into the
ring
and i think at the end of the day all of
that emotion uh
creates a fire in my belly maybe that
that logan doesn't
necessarily have um
that makes a lot of sense by the way
because i've spoken to boxing coaches
before and they've said like
that insecurity that a lot of fighters
have like the reason floyd mayweather
spends as much [__] money as he does
is because
he is insecure and that chip on the
shoulder that
people like yourself have that drives
them
i don't know i'm i'm just i'm i'm
searching for
reasons here like with you but with
logan he does seem a lot of
more of a maybe a happy-go-lucky kind of
everyone's friend kind of guy
and with you having that edge maybe that
is the reason
i i also do think though losing to ksi
changed him and i think he sort of
learned a lot from that
experience and so i think maybe once we
see him in the ring again we might
we might see a more animalistic
version of logan paul do you are you
expecting him to be more aggressive in
this next fight
i i hope so and yes like uh
he he needs to do that i think he knows
that
and i think he he regrets not
taking more risks in the ksi fight
and and i i i see that because
i i i think he was afraid to get knocked
out yeah and when you
when you fight with fear like imagine
logan paul like flat on the canvas like
nate robinson like
it's hard to come back from that and
when you fight with fear
uh it's not good you can't do that it's
bad
it's almost like you're manifesting
something bad
to happen yeah it did it did feel when i
watched it as if
logan was the more maybe skillful boxer
in there or at least on the night
he was able to display his skills more
than
ksi was but ksi was the more fearless
and i think that played into the result
um i was watching some of his footage
training the other day and yeah
i noticed some little things like him i
don't know why i'm talking about this
too but you know
i noticed him dropping his hand after he
jabs and stuff like that and
uh you know are you looking at some of
his
footage and helping him out with some
technical stuff or do you just stay out
of that
no i stay out of that i don't i don't
think he wants to hear
any notes from me really um
and you know we're coached differently
right
there's a million ways to box and every
boxer is different
and we're coached differently so he
probably is sitting there with milton
looking at me and my coaches and being
like all these guys are idiots you know
so
every everyone has their opinions on on
how people should box
and uh i sort of i sort of stay out of
that did the mayweather fight
you know when you say you were a bit
jealous at the time was that part of the
reason why you thought
he's got one of the biggest fighters
ever in
in terms of notoriety i'm going to go
after
the current main event conor mcgregor
was that part of the reason why you went
after him
no uh i went after connor the the moment
in moments after
my fight if you recall before before
floyd even confirmed his fight with
logan and i think floyd
confirmed that fight with logan after he
saw how big
of the event you know that
had happened with mike tyson and and the
knockout and how big
of a potential it had i think it was all
this
you know there wasn't one reason as to
why that fight was confirmed but i sort
of went after mcgregor
uh in the moments after my nate robinson
fight and i've been saying it for
a year and a half now that i want that
fight and uh
it just makes a ton of sense people
thought you went too far
with the wife comment um about connor
um how do you feel about that
i think uh people are soft these days
and and it sucks and people don't have a
backbone everyone's getting canceled for
every single thing that they do you
can't
step on an ant anymore because you have
to save
ever like you know what i'm saying so at
the end of the day mcgregor has called
khabib's wife a towel uh
something some sort of insult and
when i flip the script and talk [__]
towards mcgregor's wife all of a sudden
people are up in arms but when mcgregor
does it everything's fine and
he's gone after khabib's religion and
so on and so forth and he's thrown
chairs
at people and through buses and punched
old men in the face
so again it goes back to like jake paul
having a target
on my back and people just getting riled
up over
over [__] just to get riled up i noticed
in an interview when someone actually
questioned him on it
he he didn't shut you down in the way
others have he didn't say oh i've got a
problem with it i like like
the likes of canelo have you know he he
he did say you know fair play to them
they're getting in the ring
they want to make business happen good
for them and
knowing connor like we do and knowing
the business man that he is
that was a small tell in my opinion that
he isn't going to say too much now just
in case
that money back does come in handy later
on what do you think of that
100 uh hey he knows he's smart
he knows how big of a fight that will be
and
he's going in there getting paid 10
million dollars or so
to fight dustin poirier and he gets
knocked out by
poirier i'm sitting there offering him
50 million dollars
and i'm not a champion like poirier
is so i think he sees the the potential
in it
i think he sees logan and floyd doing
their fight
and again mcgregor's a smart business
guy just just like i am which is why
i've been
talking about that fight for for so long
now because
at the end of the day that's going to be
a massive business event
i know it's difficult to say it because
obviously you love your brother
and there's loyalty there but how do you
see
this floyd logan fight going
yeah it's it's uh it's it's interesting
i'm not gonna i'm not a
gonna sit here and be like a yes man to
my brother you know just
just like i would want him to tell me
the truth
on if i was doing something wrong or if
i was gonna make a mistake
i i don't there there's no path in my
opinion
to logan winning the fight do i think
he will perform better than anyone
expects
yes do i think it will be a a fight
yes do i think he comes out on top
no i mean the proof is in the pudding
floyd's gone up against the best in the
world
50 times and everyone had that chance to
throw that one
big punch that was gonna knock him out
and 50 people couldn't land it so why
now
the questions will make people excited
or interested in one way or another
because
floyd has never had knockout power he is
certainly not a big man
and he's getting old and logan
uh i think i think if i wonder if logan
had showed more punching power
if it would be more you know
excitement for i think that's the
problem is because logan was a bit
gun-shy against jj
um nobody's expecting him to come out
swinging and
and like you say maybe he's learned
those lessons and he will do is
he will leave everything in there this
time and
and hopefully so and hopefully he
can be the one it just by the science of
boxing
it's just hard it's it's just it's just
hard and and floyd is so fast and shifty
and he's a defensive boxer
so it's it's it's going to be very
difficult for logan to beat him
i'm not saying that it can't happen i'm
just not saying that it most likely will
happen
in the in the connor pourier fight their
trilogy fight has just been confirmed um
are you got any early prediction or
opinion on how that's gonna go
it's hard to say i i think poirier will
come out on top again
and the reason being is conor just
seems to have lost his sauce he he
doesn't seem as hungry there seems to be
something going on too many distractions
he's
with his family 24 7. you know after the
loss he goes on vacation for a month
traveling around the world on boats
messing around going to restaurants
seemingly getting drunk and i bet
dustin took a week off and got right
back into the gym
so i think dustin just wants it more
yeah even on the run-up to the fight i i
thought it was weird that we just seen
so much of his family around him i'm
like you're supposed to be
a savage like you you ain't supposed to
be playing happy families right now
you're supposed to be a cold hard killer
and we ain't saying that like there's
plenty of time for that
later to do that other stuff you know so
i agree with you a bit um
i wonder if if that is what you're
hoping for though because
if pourier wins then you do become
that one step closer to getting connor i
guess
uh for sure i think either way either
way
uh you know if if he loses
it might just seem like he's taking the
jake paul fight
for the hell of it you know i think it's
better if
conor wins uh
and we both come off a win and fight i
think that i think that's a lot more
hype and
again like who who is he gonna fight
after
poirier did you see the dust emporia
tweet about you where he said
if i can't finish jake paul inside three
rounds i'm a bum
uh yeah i think someone showed me this
and then it's talked about like
ben askren after that or like he was
saying that from the point of view for
brent ben askren i feel like he was
putting the pressure on ben
to to beat you inside three rounds
basically
yeah uh again people he's in for a rude
awakening and i've
i've challenged dustin poirier to spar
we're both here in south florida and uh
you're both friends with mars vidal as
well exactly yeah and
was like yo you and dustin would be
friends like i could tell like you guys
would be cool
you have the same sort of like natural
energy and vibe
uh you guys should should hang out and i
don't have anything against dustin i
think i even complimented him
for beating connor and
you know he's done amazing things you
can't take that away from him
and my by me challenging him to a spar
it's in no way coming at him i'm not
trying to start beef
everyone in this sport who's a fighter
knows that sparring is respect is a
respectful thing
i just merely want to show dustin
how good i am and and and maybe get his
co-sign
okay so i i've i've challenged him to a
spa
and we no cameras we don't have to talk
about it i told him yo dm me
hit me up let's spar we're both in south
florida uh
let's have some fun and and uh
i think it'd be interesting how's he
replied
no i i didn't dm him but i mean
obviously i'm on his radar so absolutely
you know maybe he's watching this so
uh if mazad all said we'd be friends i'm
challenging you to a friendly spa no
cameras
i don't even have to talk about it you
don't have to talk about it let's just
let's just do it
okay it feels like to me you know how
after every fight they say something
against you like
after the gib fight it was you know he's
just a youtuber after
nate robinson he's just you know an
athlete he ain't a fighter
after ben askren they're going to say
well he wasn't a good striker yada yada
it does feel like there's a stepping
stone potentially or two
in between you and a potential mega
fight with conor mcgregor
um do you have any people in mind as
those stepping stones
i mean we will see what happens honestly
after
after this fight i think we'll see a lot
of fighters come out of the woodworks to
try and call me out and challenge me
so it's all up in the air
uh there's people who i would like to
fight yeah
you know but no no one's really stepping
up to the plate
uh from ksi to
uh dennis to
you know nate diaz let's make it happen
let's run it where are you all at i have
the money
why is why is it so silent over there
they wanna everyone wants to talk about
me they wanna talk about my skill they
wanna talk about yada yadda
but i just want to talk about signing
the contracts and making it happen
i could give a [__] about anything else
so all right i've already got like three
more questions left bro
um what has fighting
taught you
man i i i would say it's really taught
me
what i've made what i'm made of you know
fighting has changed my life it's
changed who i am
and it's put me in some of the
hardest places in life and
it's really put me to the test
and i've had to step up and prove to
myself
who i am because this sport will eat you
up really fast
it's it's very difficult it's not for
everyone and there's days where you
you know you
get up and you don't want to train but
you just have to keep on fighting you
have to keep on
pushing through all that all that
adversity
and it's really i think
taught me a lot about
who jake paul is and and really
help me mature into someone that i
actually like because when i
go back and look at all these other
videos of my of myself like i can't
really even watch them i just don't
i just don't like who i was before and
so
i think fighting has taught me like who
i am and it's made me respect myself
yeah it's a funny one because on the one
hand
you most people i feel like have a
bigger ego before they get in the ring
and then when they get bullied around
that ring and
um and really put in those bad spots it
it puts you in check and it makes you
realize i'm not the big bad guy that i
thought i was but then on the other hand
once you overcome that adversity it sort
of
squashes the ego down but then it gives
you real self-worth inside like it makes
you think actually no like
yeah i'm not the guy i thought it was
but i'm actually someone better than
that i'm
you know i actually i'm brave and i you
know i've got
heart no exactly i think it instills
in a confidence that can't be replicated
anywhere else
and i can if i can box and get in that
ring
and fight someone i can do anything else
in the world
everything else seems easy compared to
compared to fighting
what is the prediction for the ben
askren fight how do you say it going
i will stop him in under six minutes
okay period okay mike drop
i like that final question um
this boxing journey just seems to keep
going for you and
it's amazing to watch as a guy who
interviewed you right at the beginning
um what do you say is the pinnacle the
culmination of all of this where do you
see
that big moment coming for you where you
feel like you're at the top
you know i think i think for me to even
try to
comprehend that right now would be doing
myself a disservice
mm-hmm you know just because
three years ago if you would have told
me that it was already this big
and already this massive the i wouldn't
wouldn't have really even believed you
so at this moment of time i don't know
where this
journey goes to i don't want to put a
cap on it
i think anything is possible and i think
this
can become as big as i want it to become
and i just have to put the work in and
keep showing up
and if i see it and and really
believe in myself and go out there and
work my ass off every single day then
this
the pinnacle of this could be something
that's talked about for
for years and years to come
i rate that mate well done on everything
that you're doing i appreciate you
coming on the podcast as well
i am betting on you big money
big money bro i'm [__] convinced
you're gonna do this and i think you're
gonna shock a lot of people and after
this
they're gonna they're gonna realize
you've got serious
talent and and good hands so you know
well done on
all the hard work mate and we'll get you
back on
hopefully before the next big fight 100
bro i appreciate you i appreciate
everything and uh hopefully we can come
to the uk
soon and hang out and drink some beers
definitely you take care of me uh that
was jake paul on the trujodi podcast hit
the like button subscribe thanks for
watching
and we'll see you later
you